I haven't really thought about this so
be prepared for some vigorous hand
waving but my understanding of P NP is
that there are a group of problems which
will call P type problems polynomial
time type problems and these are
problems that are relatively easy to
solve and then there is another group
problem called non polynomial NP and
these are really hard to solve okay
factoring is one of them you know if I
say to you what are the factors of 15
you can pretty quickly tell me always
three and five if I gave you a 10 or 20
or 100 digit number
factoring becomes really hard so NP
problems are hard to do P type easy NP
hard the only nice thing about NP type
problems is if I give you the answer you
can check it very quickly so if I if I
gave you 100 digit number you wouldn't
be able to factor it but if I gave you
the two factors you would very quickly
be obsessed oh yet no they do multiply
together to give this hundred digit
number so NP hard to solve easy to check
now the question is this our NP type
problems fundamentally different to P
type problems or maybe there's a way
that some of the NP type problems if we
were smart enough could become P type
problems is are there shortcuts that we
just don't know about it is obviously
really important for computer scientists
because there are hard problems they're
working on if there are shortcuts that
could make them easy that would be a
dream
so NP hard easy to check P type pretty
easy to do and easy to check are they
fundamentally different are they divided
or are they somehow could could NP
become P type if we were smart enough
now I'm interested in this because I've
written a book about the Simpsons and in
the Simpsons one of their Halloween
episode Treehouse of Horror six one of
the writers David X Cohen
back then he was known as David s Cohen
I think he changed his name but that
name is David s coming up back then he
embedded in one of the episodes the
equation P equals NP now by saying that
P equals NP Cohen was saying that he
believed that one day they could become
unified did anyone see the movie Tron
now that's not a popular view they take
polls of computer scientists and
mathematicians and they say look do you
think P equals NP or do you think P is
definitely not NP and the general
general consensus is that they are not
the same but David Cohen in the Simpsons
was saying well actually I kind of think
maybe one day they will become unified
in Futurama David X Cohen kind of
created Futurama along with Matt
graining it's not him it's another
writer Jeff Westbrook who was a Yale
professor in computer science before
becoming a Simpson a future AMA writer
and a Simpsons writer in Futurama there
is a scene where Fry and Amy are hiding
in a cupboard and behind them there are
files and books and cans and there are
two files and one is labeled P in one is
labeled NP so I think what Jeff
Westbrook is saying is it P and NP are
fundamentally different and they are in
separate folders and you have to keep
them in separate folders because you can
never turn NP type problem into a people
so he in Futurama we get the opposite
perspective on the problem the generally
more popular view of the problem but the
astonishing thing is that it pops up in
Futurama in primetime television as it
does with the Simpsons Oh
Oh when you say one's hard and one's
easy which you're saying for the
simplest yeah is it is this black and
white or is it a gray thing like is that
a long war card depends how fit you are
or it or the other fundamental
structural differences it's the way it's
the way that the problem increases in
difficulty would the kind of numbers
involved so factoring we talked about
factoring is easy if we have a two-digit
number
and 15 is 3 times 5 if we have a
three-digit number 121 what's 11 times
11 it's a little bit harder but so now
as the numbers get bigger
my understanding is and I'm ready for
the comments to correct me on this the
the problem increases in difficulty in a
non polynomial way that's where the NP
bit comes in so it's the way the problem
gets harder the rate at which it gets
harder is what defines it as a truly
difficult problem we'd like to thank
audible.com for sponsoring this
computerphile video and if you'd like to
check out their huge range of audio
books go to audible.com slash
computerphile and you can download one
for free we'd like to recommend Simon's
book The Simpsons and their mathematical
secrets we think both computer files and
number files really enjoy that
so get on to audible.com slash computer
file download your free book and thanks
once again to them for supporting this
computer file video 1/10 plus 2/10 does
not quite equal 3/10 because to its mind
it doesn't I might be able to do some
magic here that will read place eight
bytes in the word computer with a two by
two composite pointer of this sort